what's really funny is like Naomi is so
serious and she's so focused on set that
she never sees the practical joke coming
Gregg she never sees like I didn't do
you know my I had a I had a thing where
had a little bit of a injury it's called
a dog jaw yeah I don't know do you have
you ever I don't think I have here
[Applause]
you're
we did the other thing the other thing
though you weren't you weren't always he
was the other thing used to tease you
about on set oh yeah yeah because I I
stupidly never show weakness to will I
I told him this story about one of the
first movies that I ever did where and I
got dressed up for the premiere and you
know went with my family and friends dis
premiere and the movie started and my
part came on but it wasn't me I've been
replaced by another actress it's eat now
on the other hand I was crying
nobody's crap
right over family screener she took
pictures the red carpet interviews
everything no I would the director david
frankel I was like dude you have to do a
cut where she's not in it we have to
invite our family and show her the ones
Graham Norton here if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that then hit
subscribe or don't it's a free world but
I know what I do in that situation